i want to go to that [ __ ] lake that
has the longest name in the world
i don't know it's not like that's a town
oh it's a town yeah and it's uh
it's the town name honestly you could
have completely made that up it'll be
like yes
is that true correctly i actually was
going to make a video where i went to
that place
i actually filmed it was that was that
the town where the news anchor
pronounced
perfectly and that just went viral just
up the road from clan by the person
the temperature got to 21 celsius so
like 6 million views
yeah yeah so i i went i went there and i
filmed a video actually yeah like i have
all this footage still
and like i so wait so what's in it it's
just me going around this place
just checking out but i mean like what's
the town like it's [ __ ] dead
it was [ __ ] normal this is dead
because no one can pronounce the place
maybe i don't so it's about it was like
two hours drive from where i grew up
so i asked one of my mates i was like
hey can we go here and just film a bunch
of [ __ ]
i don't know why i was like [ __ ] it
maybe something fun will happen
nothing fun happened obviously but there
was also a climbing place that we wanted
to go to so like we'll just go there
afterwards
you mean a hill no no like a climbing
gym right oh oh
huge warehouse yeah so if you want to go
there there's a climbing
uh but i went there and it was just a
bunch of tourists from england
all right who were like old very very
old like 60s
just hanging around just checking it out
there's like a gift shop tiny
and then there's a bunch of stores and i
went in there you know asking like
because we were in a really
uh west part of wales and they normally
could speak welsh i was like oh well
maybe i'll ask around see if anyone
could speak well
yeah no one could speak [ __ ] welsh
really yeah yeah i was surprised because
normally in
that far west i think that county is the
one with the highest rate of welsh
literacy right
right so yeah nothing there nothing
there so if you've ever wondered what's
there
uh nothing no that's just a really
comically large train sign
yeah it's actually how do they fit in is
it like on like size two fonts
no no you know like the normal uh so
normally in the uk each one has like a
the standard size of uh font yeah it's
quite big
they literally just add it on there's a
really yeah there's a really funny thing
yeah there was a really funny image of a
guy like standing next to it and it's
just
like 10 meters it's really really i'll
have some footage up from the video that
mudan can just show on screen right now
it's [ __ ] huge and
yeah it's sad because none of the trains
stop there either there's there's
a really like train that goes direct to
london that doesn't stop through there
and i think it's only local trains
i mean at least you have plenty of time
to read it as you go past i want to hear
how like the train lady pronounces it
like is there like an automated message
that that
so it's shortened to like sandvik
yeah oh yeah which is still yeah awfully
long
it just sounds like you had a lot of
flame stuck right right but okay the
problem is right even with whales right
if you look around the rest of the map
like
all the town names are just as bad
really around that area to pronounce i
can't pronounce some of them without
taking like three minutes to look at it
and be like
um
yeah yeah cute little town wales don't
go there nothing don't go there
i mean i live next to some like weird
weird sounding places as well
i remember when joey came to visit i
took him and aki to uh this place called
devil's dice devil's dyke
i remember saying that oh yeah i'm going
to take you guys to devil's dike aki's
face was just like
what did you just what did you just say
because do you guys like is dyke
does die the word diet have the same
meaning yes yeah it also means like a
hill
right but there's tons of [ __ ] up
names in the uk there's like there's
places called like white knight and
stuff like that
yeah there's another place i live next
to or close to called cuckfield
yeah every time i try
every time i'm on the train and it goes
past that i just have a little laughter
myself
there's like [ __ ] fosters as well
like one of the main trains at [ __ ]
fosters finally so it's like this is the
train to
[ __ ] i feel like a five-year-old every
time i go on
go on that line i can't remember what
line it is it's a piccadilly piccadilly
line like the dark blue line
every time i wanna and because i haven't
lived in london for like
like a few years every time i go on
there and i hear it i just i just have
to laugh bust a little smurf
you're like i completely forgot to be
thinking cockfield is [ __ ] horrible
there's so many that are just like swear
words
i don't know how this is like a thing
how did we get this
how did this happen we just like in
australia we just we don't have anything
like that it's kind of sad we just have
a lot of like because you're new
yeah honestly and like a lot of the
names are just named after like uh
indigenous
names so they sound funny but they're
not like [ __ ] feet i
i i was larry talking to you about this
i was like why is there a new south
wales like
south wales was never good to begin with
why are we making another one
i don't know maybe start up from the
ground up make it a good one honestly i
don't know
like the only like funny named place in
australia that i know is uh banana
oh this is the is this a town in
queensland called banana and it has this
thing called the big banana which is the
guinness world record for the largest
banana statue in the world
wow did they just name a town after that
one
oh no it's because also like every
banana in australia grows in bananas
that probably makes more sense you
should have led with that before you
told us
that anyways i have no idea why it's
called banana but they just grow a lot
of bananas
yeah it's the only place they grow
bananas
that makes a lot of like now that you've
explained the context that makes a lot
more sense yeah exactly
so we just have stuff like that but like
i wish i [ __ ] lived in a place called
cockfield
that'd be hilarious that'd be the best
that would be the best [ __ ] like
conversation feel like it would grow
tired
yeah yeah but it's like where are you
from cockfield and you immediately get a
laugh it's like
i've already blended in with the
conversation how did you just got to
tell them in japan when they're like
and he was like no no sunday moscow oh
yeah
it's like where you live
whales